Transcription: Géraldine Géraldine
Relecteur: eric vautier
Jusqu’au 20e siècle,
les musiciens avaient
à leur disposition uniquement
des instruments acoustiques
pour composer leur musique.
Ils ont réalisé leurs plus grands
chefs-d’œuvre avec des pianos,
des violons, des guitares,
et ces instruments à l’époque,
leur suffisaient à créer
de magnifiques musiques.
Cependant, un jour,
ils se sont posés
une question fondamentale
pour l’évolution de la musique :
qu’est-ce qui fait le son ?
De quoi est composé le son ?
Ils se sont aidés des travaux
des scientifiques,
en partie le travail de Fourier
qui a démontré sa célèbre « transformée ».
Et ils ont compris que le son,
les ondes sonores
étaient seulement une superposition
d’ondes sinusoïdales
de fréquences différentes
et d’amplitudes différentes.
Voyez ici le signal blanc qui est une
somme de tous les autres signaux colorés.
C’est-à-dire qu’en comprenant
comment était fait le son
qu’ils utilisaient
pour créer leurs morceaux,
ils ont pu le travailler
pour essayer d’obtenir un son
qui était plus proche
de ce qu’ils espéraient.
Donc, ils ont commencé à travailler
avec des micros
et à transformer ce son,
ce qui a créé la guitare électrique,
très utilisée par tous les groupes
de Rock à l’époque.
Le son était capté par des micros,
transformé et réuni par des haut-parleurs.
Mais ce qui est plus intéressant, c’est
qu’ils ont essayé de construire un son
de toutes pièces, en travaillant sur
les ondes sinusoïdales, à la base.
Ils ont compris
qu’en additionant certaines ondes,
ils pouvaient créer n’importe quel son,
et ce fut l’apparition des synthétiseurs,
qui permettaient de jouer de la musique
à partir de sons programmés
entièrement par l’être humain.
Les synthétiseurs ont fait
beaucoup de progrès
et de nos jours, il est possible de
produire quasiment n’importe quel son,
que ce soit un son
d’un instrument acoustique
ou un son complètement
inventé par l’homme.
La musique électronique n’a pas remplacé
la musique traditionnelle.
Elle l'a seulement complétée
et lui a apporté une richesse incroyable.
De nombreux courants musicaux sont nés
à partir de ces découvertes,
et de ce travail sur le son.
Vous devez vous demander
pourquoi je vous parle
de la musique d’hier,
alors que le thème c’est :
la cuisine de demain ?
C’est parce que la cuisine de demain
s’inspire de la musique d’hier
pour pouvoir évoluer.
Elle va utiliser les grands concepts
qui ont permis à la musique
de se développer
mais elle va les appliquer
à la nourriture.
Nous devons d’abord nous demander :
qu’est-ce que nous mangeons actuellement ?
Nous mangeons de la viande, des légumes,
des fruits, des féculents.
Mais de quoi sont composés
ces aliments ?
Quelle est la différence entre une
viande de bœuf et une viande d’agneau ?
Qu’est-ce qui fait la différence entre
la chair du saumon et de la crevette ?
Pourquoi une poire, une pomme,
qui grandissent
toutes les deux sur un arbre
ont des goûts si différents ?
Et même plus loin, qu’est-ce qui se passe
quand nous cuisinons ?
Ces viandes ont un goût
différent à la base,
mais on voit que lorsqu’on les cuisine,
on transforme leur goût et leur structure
et le résultat qui arrive
dans nos assiettes
n’a rien à voir avec le goût du départ.
Prenez l’exemple
d’une miche de pain grillée au four,
elle n’a pas du tout le même goût
qu’une miche de pain pas cuite.
Nous allons comprendre ce qui se passe
dans la nourriture grâce à un exemple,
la cerise, et aux travaux
d’un grand scientifique, Hervé This,
qui a posé les fondements de la cuisine
que je suis en train de vous présenter.
La cerise possède
une consistance, une texture.
Cette texture va être créée à partir
de pectine qui va faire un réseau
dans lequel va être emprisonnée l’eau,
cela va créer la pulpe de la cerise.
Elle possède une odeur,
cette odeur va être due
à un assemblage
d'une centaine de composés odorants.
Ils vont avoir des proportions
différentes dans la cerise,
dans les différentes variétés de cerises,
et ils vont avoir un rôle primordial
dans le goût, et c’est ce qui va
nous permettre, en grande partie,
de percevoir le goût de la cerise.
Quand ils vont arriver dans la bouche,
ils vont se volatiliser
et par notre expiration,
les composés vont arriver
dans la cavité nasale
et c’est à ce moment-là
que nous allons pouvoir les goûter.
La cerise a une couleur surtout due
aux anthocyanes et au bêtacarotène.
Qu’est-ce que la saveur ?
La saveur, c’est tout ce qui
va être capté par la langue.
On connaît les sucrés,
- il y a plein de types de sucrés -
les acides, les amers, les salés
et aussi les piquants,
du piment, du poivre, etc.
Les élèments nutritionnels,
je ne vais pas m’étendre trop dessus
car tout le monde est bien au courant
de la nutrition de nos jours
et ça ne fait plus débat.
Vous voyez bien qu’un aliment
aussi simple que la cerise
est quand même d’une richesse
et d’une complexité incroyables.
Chaque composé qui la constitue
a un rôle bien distinct,
que ce soit pour participer
à l’odeur de l’aliment,
à sa saveur, à sa texture,
tous les composés ont leur rôle.
On va aller un peu plus loin pour étudier
un autre aliment, c’est l’amande.
Cette amande, on va se concentrer sur
son odeur, et la comparer à la cerise.
En comparant l’odeur de l’amande
et l'odeur de la cerise,
on se rend compte qu’il y a des composés
en commun, et principalement un.
Ce composé, on l’a appelé « Amerise »,
car il est présent dans l’amande
et dans la cerise.
Et cela crée quelque chose d’incroyable,
parce que, maintenant,
on sait que le goût de la cerise
n’est pas seulement le goût de la cerise,
mais est créé à partir
d’une multitude de composés.
Mais ces composés
se retrouvent aussi dans l’amande.
Ça veut dire que nos aliments
sont constitués par des composés,
et une base commune de ces composés
crée tous les aliments.
Il y a des ponts entre les aliments,
tous les aliments possèdent
des composés en commun
et par exemple, l’amerise
est présente dans plein d’aliments,
que ce soit la noix de Saint Jacques,
la fraise, la jacinthe, elle est présente.
La jacinthe n’est pas un aliment,
mais dans toutes ces choses-là,
elle participe soit beaucoup, soit peu,
mais elle participe à leur odeur.
Cette base commune de composés,
on la retrouve dans le vin.
Tout le monde ici,
losque vous dégustez un vin,
vous cherchez à découvrir
des notes de fruits rouges,
des notes de banane, des notes de cuir,
des notes de mousse.
D’où viennent-elles ?
Elles ne viennent pas du vigneron,
il n’a pas décidé de mettre
des fruits rouges dans son vin
et de les mélanger avec du cuir.
C’est juste que le raisin de base,
lors de sa transformation,
a fait apparaître des composés
que l’on retrouve aussi
dans toutes ces choses-là.
Cette base commune de composés
est incroyable,
elle nous permet de comprendre
complètement
comment sont faits nos aliments,
et jusqu’ici,
nous avons toujours utilisé les aliments
comme un tout indissociable.
Nous prenions les aliments,
mais en prenant un aliment,
nous prenions une centaine de composés,
et si vous vous souvenez
du parallèle avec la musique,
vous voyez où je veux en venir.
Demain, nous ne cuisinerons plus
avec des aliments
mais nous cuisinerons
avec des composés purs.
Cette cuisine s’appelle «note à note».
Chaque aliment devient une palette
dans laquelle le cuisinier
pourra piocher pour composer ses plats.
Cette cuisine est progressiste
et avant-gardiste.
Elle s’inspire des expérimentations
des plus grands chefs cuisiniers qui ont
déjà commencé la cuisine note à note.
La cuisine note à note peut
se déguster soit chez Pierre Gagnaire,
qui fut le premier à élaborer
un plat note à note,
ou chez Andrea Camastra,
franco-italien basé à Varsovie,
qui a actuellement un restaurant
qui propose des plats
qui ont au moins 10% d’éléments
qui sont composés note à note.
Ces chefs ne cherchent pas à reproduire
les goûts que l’on trouve dans la nature.
Ils n’ont aucun intérêt à reproduire
le goût d’une fraise, le goût d’un steak.
Pourquoi ils n’ont aucun intérêt ?
Parce qu’ils ont à leur disposition
les meilleurs producteurs du monde
et s’ils veulent les meilleurs produits,
ils iront les trouver
chez les producteurs.
Par contre,
l’intérêt de la cuisine note à note,
c’est de pouvoir créer des goûts
qu’ils ont envie
de faire goûter à leur clientèle.
C’est pour créer des nouvelles textures,
c’est pour créer un tout nouveau monde,
une toute nouvelle cuisine, et pouvoir
vraiment y ajouter leur talent artistique.
Ici, qu’est-ce que vous voyez ?
Un sous-bois.
Un sous-bois plein de nature,
plein de végétation,
c’est vert, c’est beau, ça donne
envie de s’y promener, de s'y balader.
Pourtant, ici, tout est naturel
mais rien n’est comestible.
Grâce à la cuisine note à note,
vous comprenez maintenant
de quoi sont faits
les éléments qui nous entourent.
Et, vous ne voyez plus maintenant
un arbre, une fougère et de la mousse,
mais vous voyez des milliers de composés
qui constituent ces éléments.
Vous voyez que l’arbre a une structure.
Pourquoi on ne mange pas de bois ?
Parce que la structure
n’est pas comestible,
mais tout le reste, ou en grande partie,
le reste qui se trouve dans l’arbre,
pourrait être comestible
et pourrait être mangé.
En cuisinant note à note,
on peut déterminer les composés
qui sont présents dans le bois,
et vous savez très bien
que le bois est d’une richesse incroyable.
Les producteurs d'alcools
l’ont bien compris,
puisqu’ils font vieillir leurs alcools
en fûts de bois.
Il y a une richesse incroyable
et on pourrait utiliser ces composés.
La mousse aussi. C’est une cuisine
qui va s’inspirer de la nature,
mais qui va pouvoir aussi
aller chercher au-delà de la nature,
parce que vous avez
toutes les odeurs que vous aimez,
par exemple
l’odeur de la pluie, d’un livre, du neuf,
sont toutes des odeurs
qui sont très intéressantes.
Et pourquoi on n’a jamais cuisiné
avec l’odeur d’un livre, par exemple ?
Ce serait incroyable de déterminer
quels sont les composés
responsables de l’odeur d’un livre
et de les utiliser dans la cuisine.
On aurait l’impression
de manger quelque chose
qui s’apparenterait à un livre.
A la vue de ces possibilités infinies
et pour pouvoir développer
la cuisine note à note,
nous avons décidé de créer «Iqemusu»
pour rendre accessible la cuisine
de demain à tout le monde.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)